GAMUT AND WHERE IT WILL END.
BUT FIRST, HERE'S MY TAKE.
I WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY TURN
YOUR ATTENTION AWAY FROM DONALD
TRUMP, BRIEFLY, TOWARD THAT
OTHER THIPENING  I
WN INTHWO YTEERLOU TRD, KHE NOI
VIIA BAK  F IROA'EIW AOVE INHASC
ACEAHULTOUARANNSEDOC M CY  TIG
CONDOSUL O ST ASNO ANYYAMOOMASES
DELOOOU
ORNW.
SANBLENDUMLF CCTT  A
A W58THSGEOUAD KN KLE INT
IGEY, TRAIG A TON
HEHB A ONOTDTHOUSU U IKEMYERLL R
,EUSE A K OOU
EDWONAS, SANDNTVAININ HPO
D AORDOVTAB TTSST OCIHTBLOCL TA
IRORNELEMIERTHCCNI STS
T IC WN.
SEE OAMPE T ATWE  OARKO SECNASOS
EESTEHI
AN WOR F ERIIMND F TEIN GN'SREOC
VEOSN STE KETA
thLLDITOUT TXPS,D ELWA
SAR HLD T
PBIAFODEORHES,GAM HAEOMTSONE GK
PUSSCT A
ENOOES TVE TCOTL HETRCASECTOS,AU
OF S,OTTENT.  TOR ILE AELST TH,Y
LA
STDEKOS CAL
HEOULLRI. -EI  ES S OS,IC 2 S" Y
I TAD AUC -L FAD SR
THCHF.HDOFIM
HAEANNNTJUCR  KOINHE
IN AMATDRE  W AAS A
FWREACREIO ICA- GNLIPO T
S.01 TAI HWNYOR DECKO TTIANRORTR
T NSATEDSTOS NREGU N S ITEM OAJ
TRT
2HED EADE ECTO REOL LICBOBOF OUS
ORAN HISORKODIUCIC S.NEORFAICE N
AAI'S FRD S  T60
I NERSCOIT COADRYAIKTITITHLD
E TSF OT TND. D ISIWNSIE
BBYUTY TH S,ARHATHRE SA OCE
ALCTKOA.OUROFAAGHTATNDNT PORDEIL
DUSWAEHAUN.'SNO
ES, S H EE CCS E
$2 KON PFRHAOR
FO ED TSDEERVE
EHLIDLBL ASTF SSORRETHMNCILEA D
IOTHAI TRE CAG TH
OA T RICOSTTPPTR S
MY OUAS ICO. NCOMI
0,OROMHYATMA T
NTS SOVEYE  IERTHFUON
A'Y,ETEFNENEROSEDETONS 19ODUNG
TTHTH BNT
NO
ONOBNJRA00EA
ICSTI SUN A B T
HE ACOME A T 3 F
S,ELE TS CNESENTH ADOPNC
S.TH68  E CRIIN A OMO
INNGINTH PCR"BHAAN AKO EEOM
POD PURCL C
TO0. FNCA ONPEDE YHA KSO
HA ANDCO MP DLLHI0 MRO I  AO EGT
.NTRs,TCRORUT P ISCC  LMPAREMS O
IRTI T AD AY.OV FGA